foreign
[Music]
there's a little bit of backlash going
on
for a a very unfortunate Virginia
country club
because of their 911 themed menu
what are you [ __ ] kidding me this is
okay as a comedic mind I'm immediately
thinking it's a 911 theme party it's
like the Twin Towers Fest right or some
[ __ ] you come in and then it's like it's
like you got
twin corns or some [ __ ] right when it
comes out it's like two corn on a cob
everything's in pears yeah it's on pears
with the with the little airplane
to a crisp yeah chard Chard is a good
Rebrand double grilled corn double
grilled pretty close really and then
there's a little half size third corn on
the right that somehow falls on its own
yeah exactly exactly I don't know how
this got here yeah I didn't order this
didn't even have butter on it corn seven
corn seven what so this country club has
a 911 themed food food menu that
included such items as a chocolate silk
Pentagon pie that sounds pretty good
though the two two nine seven seven
chowder which is how many people died
during 9 11.
okay that's [ __ ] crazy uh first
responder flatbread okay that's cool
yeah what flapper you don't like
flatbread it's like a numb why is it
first responder because it yeah they
need more ideas because yeah that's what
I was thinking I was like what else
could you add on this is actually way
more creative than I thought yeah they
had um if you're looking for a taste for
every of everything you could have the
never forget sampler oh how about the
how about the uh rotisserie fireman like
it's like a it's like a chicken but it's
like burnt to a crisp sounds delicious
yeah so why why are they getting mad at
that too soon
[Applause]
so it sounds like you don't see a
problem with it uh I don't know do you
see a problem it sounds like you're
putting the periodic seal of approval
that's I don't know about okay okay is
it are these guys like they all are a
family of
some of the Fallen people and they're
just trying to have a good way to kind
of cope with oh that would be cool
they're a bunch of Pete Davidsons I
didn't think this was a joke I thought
this was like a French chef like I want
to commemorate
and then he's like and then he goes oh I
have ideas he goes we will have a cake
of Twin Towers we will do this and he
wants to like he's so okay there's not
enough holidays in September what's up I
was like is this like one of those like
overzealous like patriotic friendships
yeah he's not a Wolfgang Puck kind of
guy yeah I didn't see anything about it
he's very American yeah yeah yeah I get
it it's kind of it's kind of stupid that
they didn't put that in the article
because I'm thinking if they're planning
this dinner right in September there's
not that many holidays to choose from
that's true I agree with you got Labor
Day Labor Day that's it and he got 9 11.
So You Gotta Throw Another one in the
mix but maybe these are maybe these are
the types who are like it's a little
early for Halloween and everyone's doing
Halloween right now it's a little hack
to do Halloween already yeah so like
let's do something else and then like
get the juice in the 911 train a little
bit they didn't want to do Labor Day
that's that's in September what is Labor
Day is it like no work day it's like
yeah no work day so then they wouldn't
want to theme a no work day because then
it's like you don't want to work yeah
but people would think they're closed
yeah uh so Bart I know you don't drink
but maybe you could have a little sip of
the remember teeny I would drink some of
that yeah remember teeny which is a key
lime Rum Cream Coconut Rum pineapple
juice splash of cream served in a served
with whipped cream honey gram Rim that
sounds like [ __ ] dude yeah yeah and they
throw it in your face coconut cream
ground zero coffee that would be that's
cool that's cool zero yeah that's nice
what other like puns out of 911 can they
make I wish the pun guy was here huh
yeah yeah the insensitive pun guy yeah
whatever you had Anthony dude the thing
about Anthony Lee is he always has the
best 911 puns
911 and cancer puns well this is off
camera though he does it off camera yeah
yeah have you ever seen him trying to
console someone with like a terminal
illness he makes a lot he just puns away
he has a lot of good childhood leukemia
jokes he's like I bet you were dying to
hear that one like is that one of his
dreams like they're going I go gonna
bring it up again that's what I do yeah
I mean as the biggest 911 denier that I
know like she's really [ __ ] good he's
really [ __ ] good at all the 911
really make you believe it never
happened yeah yeah he's got some
interesting points he almost got me one
time you know yeah he had a dance about
how 911 is not real that made me weep
he took two of the tallest guys and
couldn't just
and then
he can take you there with his body
movement because he's not good he's that
good he's that good he could tell a
story that guy yeah you know he he
copied a little bit of that like Smooth
Criminal Michael Jackson move when they
like lean like that but then in his
story The Towers come back up because it
didn't really happen but he can hang out
at the bottom for a while yeah he was
hanging for a little bit and then he
came back which civilizes how many
months it took for how many years it
took to build the Freedom Power yeah
exactly which is why he comes up again
singularly because you guys got to see
it you guys was like the the it was just
a real estate scam we're not doing
enough Justice Yeah so basically the
Country Club's apologizing as usual
um
what country is this is that here this
is Virginia
the French part of Virginia British
Virginia yeah one of those gated
communities has like a a restaurant and
that's what this is so they're just
completely oblivious to the rest of the
world and whatever because they look
like you know what's funny out of all
places though I would think like a
country club in Virginia would be so
[ __ ] pro-military and like so serious
they would take the [ __ ] like I didn't
think they would joke about [ __ ] well I
think they were actually looking at this
as like hey this is kind of sick you
know like like remembrance kind of like
the 911 oysters is kind of like you know
kind of a beautiful thing they're ahead
of their time man because we're here
still like stuck on oh you shouldn't
make fun of this they're like ah we you
know we've been there done that let's
move on let's make fun of it now I think
no but they're taking it seriously but
how many tragedies could you make into a
restaurant theme
which ones can't you do which ones can't
you do do Holocaust that's we could do
Waco barbecue that's because it's Texas
barbecue yeah but that's way more
light-hearted than the 911 version true
but then they got roasted inside but
it's a small it's a wake house small
it's a Waco small cows that's [ __ ] up
right Cedar Smokehouse how about a
flight of 93 beers so it's like 93
flight 90. they should talk to you to
add that in there it'd be kind of sick I
can't believe they didn't think about
that all right that's the easy one well
like as far as like National tragedies
In Our Lifetime that happen on U.S soil
it's only what 9 11 right
what else I guess I mean there's always
I don't know that's it there's the tower
seven of onion rings
there's that [ __ ] marathon where the
guy oh the Boston box imagine imagine
making a restaurant called with bomb ass
food right I don't know about that dude
those would be horrible restaurant ideas
they're terrible it's a bummer the whole
time you want to do that it's a poor
taste unless you did a restaurant idea
based on a serial killer and it's cereal
bunnies bundies Bundys would be blunties
yeah yeah and you eat it out you got to
go to the guy's trunk
hey can you help me over here and you're
like they're like and the husband and
wife you're like that's what he would
say this is great it's realistic
there's a restaurant out here called uh
Alondra Hot Wings no pizza oh yeah but
but but the thing is when you go in it's
just a [ __ ] portrait of mob bosses
all over which is kind of sick yeah
that's cool it is sick but if you think
about it that's like that's like a 911
restaurant at the mom Museum in Vegas
you go downstairs and they have like a
whole bar in there and it's all themed
like that so why is it okay to have that
but you can't have like because a good
[ __ ] a like a like a Jihad [ __ ]
like shawarma place because the only
thing they hot jambalaya
is that the same culture
the only thing they proved was tax
evasion good point it's a occasion
[ __ ] Al-Qaeda restaurant hey that's
already done with dude it's Creole food
organization right so it's a criminal
organization but it's like hey let's eat
some [ __ ] Pizza while you do this but
it's like what but monsters are such a
it's so close to America like we have so
many movies of mobsters where we're like
dude these guys are sick it's American
history but until the al-Qaeda one comes
out where they make them cool we're not
gonna be on board dude we used to there
was this this restaurant here was like a
hot pot shabu-shabu it was a communist
Hot Pot themed
the weirdest [ __ ] [ __ ] to me how is
it communist themed everyone everybody
was wearing red stars and wearing
communist like outfits oh [ __ ] yeah and
that's just the weird thing to see in
America but I saw it in Vietnam and it
was just so [ __ ] odd to me there was
a a communist coffee house right you go
in there's like [ __ ] pictures of like
all these Communists yeah you could get
like a communist t-shirt and I I was
like oh wait but this is a communist
country so it's not weird it's just like
my American head is like we would never
do that and then like out here it's the
same thing as having like a full-on
patriotic American restaurant so it's
like it was just weird to me dude what
if Vietnam had a restaurant that was
like this where they commemorated like
the Gulf of Tonkin what yeah what is
what's that well that's what started
something that never happened yeah yeah
yeah another 911 conspiracy theory bro
oh damn that's why I don't know about it
well it's stupid anyway it doesn't
matter okay
foreign
[Music]
[Music]